don't think you're trying to hide
anything which personally I think is
kind of refreshing yes I think you've
learned the hard way like a lot of leads
that have had a difficult time people
been hard on you like let's just call it
what it is and they're gonna be hard on
you something we're gonna like what you
do some people aren't so you just kind
of have to live your life and cancel out
all the other noise and it seems like
you're doing that but back to what you
said you said you're taking it slow and
you're not dating yet you literally
called where you are home right now you
said I'm just making this my home base
that kind of sounds fast to see each
other every day we're gonna quarantine
you Kelly have you and their own rooms
we got Sophie here to Dustin's dogs so
we're having a party if you get that
it's just that it having like obviously
it sounds like so much fun you know to
have a group of people because a lot of
people are alone right now but it also
doesn't sound like you're taking a slow
I'm just I'm just saying way to get to
know somebody is like this I understand
that but I will use the defense that we
are quarantine together so we have no
choice but to spend all of our time
together and I just I'm grateful for
that very grateful because we get along
so well I just yeah I look up there and
just have so much respect for herself so
here's my segue into moving on do you
feel like at this point cuz how many
weeks have you been quarantined in
Chicago yes and now like a little over
to baby so do you feel like you know
Kelly better than you knew Hannah Ann or
Madison at this point yes yeah now if if
couples can make it through this
quarantine when you are locked in
together 24/7 you can make it through
anything after this it's very true yeah
no I've definitely gotten over very well
everything that kind of makes her tick
and just kind of like a noise and all
that stuff it's so good
you're still there is Peter better in
real life or on the show oh my god
real life nope some homes like some
parts of him that you saw worth like
necessarily him but I even used to say
on the show I was like there's Peter
Webber and then there's actually the
Peter or The Bachelor Peter and you know
there's but it can you stop saying that
and I was like no it's true I met him
outside of this and he's so much cooler
than thank you no absolutely so you feel
like if you met Peter well you didn't
beat him in real life before but like
you guys could hit it off oh for sure
yeah I think so yeah it's definitely a
it's yes it's a compliment take it it's
a fine line to try to be both the same
person you see on TV is the same person
you are in person so well and that's the
thing I think as Leeds like the show is
edited in a way to have certain
storylines and there's so much that
happens that can't be portrayed on TV
and so I think for everyone anyone who's
ever been on the show there's so much
more people are way funnier or more
charismatic than what they come across
and Peter I mean I've met you now a few
times in person and like you really are
just this very warm big-hearted like fun
charismatic guy that that I think we saw
it a good part of it on the show but I
think that there's so much more and so
you know regardless of what happened
throughout the entire season and it
didn't pan out I'm sure as anyone had
expected I think you are on your own
path and I'm so happy you were hour
about sorry I really am
yeah you seem happy like we've talked to
you a couple of times in studio you're
different
[Music]